another launch another f in the chat huh
all right so let me start off this video
by saying this is what you need to know
about the new rtx 3080 ti it's meant to
be
almost as fast as the rtx 3090 in gaming
but
it's only as fast as the rtx 3070
in mining okay it costs a cool 11.99 and
yeah we all know this is going to be
marked up like crazy
yet because of that mining limitation it
might make its way into the hands of a
few more gamers and look everyone here
at harvard canucks
asks the same questions you are when
nvidia start to talk to us about this
gpu
why are they releasing it now instead of
trying to improve the stock
of the situation of existing cards that
even we
can't buy and then why doing this in the
middle of a shortage
anyways now the problem here is that
nvidia is basically diverting cores that
could have been used to make the rtx
3080 stock situation
a little bit better but instead using
them to produce an even higher priced
card
meanwhile there's still people waiting
for their rtx 3080s
making this purely a business move from
nvidia and nothing more because let's be
honest the last six months since the rtx
3080 launch has been the total
show limited supply super high demand
tariffs
scalpers and even plenty of greed from
retailers and board partners
it isn't even a cool meme anymore and
rather something that
has become a lot more serious that could
have lasting effects on the whole pc
gaming space
and to be frank i hate it it's easy to
make fun of the stock situation and call
this launch
nvidia greed or laugh while every gpu is
sold in seconds
but on the flip side this might be the
first time we're seeing a company at
least take
some steps to discourage large-scale
mining that means the rtx 3080 ti will
be the first car to include a
hardware-based
hash rate limiter not only that but
other than the cores going into the rtx
3090 every new geforce gpu coming off
the assembly line
will have the same cut down hash rates
so is this finally going to give some
new sense of hope to gamers
well maybe but maybe not show off the
cool build and not the cables with the
new corsair 5000 series
welcome the all-new interior you'll
appreciate for whatever build you desire
without any hassle of cable management
and appropriate cooling all around
with proper dust filtration on all three
models check it out below alright so
let's start right off with the elephant
in the room and that's
is mining first of all any new rtx 3080
3070 3060 ti
and the 3060 cores will have that
built-in hardware limiter
that's supposed to cut the hash rates in
about half and no this isn't a joke
piece of software but a true
hardware-based solution that will be
labeled as lhr on the packaging for
light hash rates since
until stock of the new original cards
sell through both will be around at the
same time
the ti cards will natively have this cut
down from day one
so they won't have the lhr name oh and
the rtx 3090 will keep being sold as
is without the lhr version so right
about now you're probably wondering
if this will drive up the demand and
prices of these older gpus
even more and the answer is absolutely
yes at least in the short term until
lhr cards become more widely available
so what does that mean for the rtx 3080
ti
well like i said in the intro it might
cost a ton of money but at stock
settings
it has only a bit higher ethereum hash
rate than an rtx 3070
while chugging down a heck a lot more
power i should also mention our crew in
montreal was able to lower the ti
to 58 power or about 205 watts and not
lose
any mining performance so take that for
what it is but
ethereum and dagger hashimoto algorithms
are not the only games
in town for gpu mining is just most
profitable right now
and is the only one being targeted by
this limiter right now there are smaller
algorithms like octopus where the rtx
3080 ti
still packs a full hash rate punch
basically nvidia is not cutting off
mining altogether and that's good news
for hobbyists who
use their gpus to make some extra cash
in their downtime
since those other algorithms are
available through platforms like
nicehash so by targeting ethereum
exclusively
nvidia's intent is to make those gpus a
lot less desirable
for the mining companies and
professional miners who buy
truckloads of those things i wouldn't
put past them to somehow find a work
around the toe like they did
with a software limiter but honestly
will that do a darn thing about
availability
absolutely no at least not right away
first of all we're living in a world
where miners are paying
way over a thousand dollars for the rtx
or the rx 5700 xt
that mine around the rtx 3070 levels
which really makes the rtx 3080 ti
price point at 1199 the perfect
gpu for markups through the roof
and even if some magical land massive
mining corporations don't want them
there's just so much pent-up demand for
gamers still waiting for their chance to
like
update then these rtx 3080 ti's are
going to be grabbed up
in no time anyways let's get on to the
gaming track in the normal market nvidia
would have had to respond
a lot sooner to the rx 6900 xd by either
lowering the rtx 3090 price
or launching the rtx 3080 ti earlier but
they didn't
mostly because they were able to sell
every single one of those cards and aim
these been pretty
much unable to produce more than a
handful of those cards anyway in terms
of specs you basically get
95 of the way to an rtx 3090 except with
half the memory
but like eben mike saw in past videos 12
gigabytes is more than enough for
literally
every gaming situation and yes even in
8k
there are cuts to both core and memory
frequencies along with the number of
cuda cores
and texture units all of which points
towards nvidia using the ga 102 cores
that didn't make the cut for the rtx
3090 but while the 3090 is still
technically the king of the hill
due to things like internal clock
timings and variations between cores
the ti could still come out on top every
now and then the bigger comparison
however will probably be against the rtx
and in that respect there is a pretty
massive spec bump for the ti
and yes even with its price but what the
rtx 380's ti founders edition carries
forward from its smaller brother
is the overall design of the card it has
the same dual slot layout and uses a
unique push-pull design that nvidia
first shot off six months ago
i mean it looks great fits into most
cases and gets almost as good uh
temperatures
as the much bigger designs and yes i'm
looking at you gigabyte with your
massive
almost four slot graphics card it also
uses the same 12 pin power connector as
the other fe cards which exits
in the world's worst position but i
guess they couldn't be
avoided since that's where the pcb ends
anyway
the only real change you can see from
the outside is a subtle polished metal
edge around the fans where the original
rtx 3080
uses a matte finish meanwhile the rear
has all the basics including hdmi 2.1
and
three displayport 1.4 ports
unfortunately no usbc here
and this is also where there's another
small change instead of the gunmetal
gray on the 3080
the ti has a chrome finish now before i
get into the actual
benchmark results it's important to
understand how the rtx 3080 ti lines up
with other nvidia gpus from
a temperatures noise and power
consumption standpoint
even though the ti uses the same cooler
as the much more efficient rtx 3080
temperatures were pretty well behaved
throughout testing as a matter of fact
they never got anywhere near
to nvidia's maximum so that's really
good news those temperatures did not
come with too much of an increase in
noise either
since the ti state pretty well behaved
it wasn't the quietest of the cards here
but it was barely audible
over our system fans power consumption
on the other hand
is right in line with the rtx 3090 and
our sample at least actually peaked a
little bit higher
i think the most interesting thing here
is how the rtx 30 ti compares with the
rx 6900 xt
and that is it actually sucks down a lot
more power
so amd does hold a slight edge in
overall efficiency now with specs like
these
performance at 1440p is pretty much tied
with the rtx 3090
uh and 12 to 20 faster than the rtx 3080
provided a game is not cpu bottlenecked
and yes these cards are so
fast it's pretty easy to get them into a
cpu limited territory
even at 1440p but even though this looks
really impressive
finding any of these cards at nvidia's
mythical suggested retail price point
will probably be impossible it's a lot
extra to pay for that kind of uplift
i mean sure against the completely
overpriced rtx 3090 it looks like
an okay value but the 3080 or even the
6800 xt
are really well positioned even if
they're at the bottom of these charts
and let's not forget the rx 6900xt
which is even harder to find than any of
these geforce cards
but it still competes pretty well
considering it's supposed to cost
a thousand dollars moving on to 4k and
it's pretty much the same story as with
1440p
since positioning of these high-end gpus
is rarely if ever
changes when it comes to crazy high
resolutions framerates take a plunge but
you can see how the rtx 3090's
double memory size does absolutely
nothing
so again it's overall just two to four
percent faster than the rtx 3080 ti and
against the rx 6900xt
i've got to hand it to amd since they've
designed a really competitive gpu
again if you find one gg moving on to
ray tracing when it comes to nvidia
versus their own
cards basically follow the last two
benchmarks the rtx 3080 ti matches
or is just under the rtx 3090s
performance
while the amd cards fall a bit behind
but the interesting thing here is that
with the last few drivers uh the rx
6900xt and the 6800xd
have become a bit more competitive it'll
be more interesting to see how this
plays out in next few months
as both teams launch more games that
support ray tracing now what about
programs that impact the workflow of
creators and both nvidia and amd
claim their gpus speed up this workflow
but
by how much well this is a new area for
us but it touches on a lot of the
applications that we use on a daily
basis
so starting with blender cycles
rendering and this is one area where
nvidia clearly has the lead
but let's be honest for a second even
though they claim the rtx 3090 is built
for creators
in this situation it actually isn't
since the much cheaper
3080 ti gets identical results moving on
to premiere and this is something really
interesting
no matter how many times we ran our
custom output test
the rtx 3080 ti kept leading by a pretty
wide margin
again and again and again and again
there's no real way to explain this
other to say that
these are the results that we got and
that's it on the other hand
amd's been working very closely with the
blackmagic team on optimizing resolve
for new radeon cards and is starting to
show at least from a rendering
perspective the rx 6900xt and the 6800xt
just walk all over everything nvidia has
got right now
even with studio drivers that's pretty
impressive well done amd and so i guess
that wraps things up in the end
if this was a normal year with the usual
rollouts of graphics cards the rtx 3080
ti
would be a pretty good addition to
nvidia's lineup right
it performs well and it almost matches
the super expensive rtx 3090 in most
games
but i also have to wonder if nvidia's
strategy here was to release a card like
the rtx 3090
which is so stupidly overpriced that it
makes
everything underneath and even expensive
cards like the 3080 ti
look like a better deal anyway the real
question here is whether or not nvidia's
mining limiters
will make any difference uh they're sure
making a big deal about it
aren't they like it's it's all that's
all they're talking about
and the answer to this would be a bit
more complicated in the short term
the answer is no because demand from
even regular gamers is so
high that every damn gpu will sell no
matter what
in the long run however no honestly
nvidia is looking out for themselves
before anyone else like amd and intel
their company living at the will of
their short
shore holders shareholders and that
means
ultimately making money so introducing
cards with capped hash rates
for the gaming market while pushing
miners to the more expensive options
is a win-win situation for nvidia in the
end
hopefully this leads to better
availability i mean we always say that
for you know less scalping and better
prices for everyone
and at least some hope for improvement
but i guess
we'll just have to wait and see what
happens i really don't care how they
swing the story this isn't about helping
gamers because the 3080ti
still costs 1200 and above
and that feels like a money grab before
anything else i can see it now retailers
asking the rtx 3080 buyers if they want
to cancel their orders
in order to buy a higher-end price card
i'm sure this is going to be happening
everywhere
really i'm thinking by the time the dust
settles this might be just another
expensive gpu you cannot buy
and that would piss us all off even more
but let me know what you think of the
new
ti launch press f in the chat i'm dmitry
thanks so much for watching check out
this other relevant content
subscribe for more and i'll talk to you
in the next video
[Music]